what's what's your what's your belief in
what's legal in the UK come aggressive
I'm I'm I'm ask I'm asking a I'm asking
a
question me being aggressive is
different I'm I'm not aggressive you're
you're acting aggressive you're acting
aggressive I'm not acting aggressive who
who Who's who's the majority of beiles
white middleaged men it's not even our
problem it's it's it's a white middle AG
are you are you British I'm okay where
you from I don't know what you look like
bro I'm from yeah I'm well I'm asking
you a question I'm
asking let's talk about life let's talk
about love if we talk about love then we
should talk about us and if we're
talking about us we need to talk about
growth they talk about you what they
should talk about both it's easier to
hate now and harder to care we used to
offer help now we gossip and stare
comment like swipe share hate used to be
was Mary Mary was 12 did you know that
but did you know that Mary was 12 when
she uh when she gave she became an adult
at 9: no it's against law what what we
talking which law is G is what we
believe as as in in
England what's your what's your belie in
what's legal in UK come aggressive
I'm I'm not I'm ask I'm asking a I'm
asking a
question me being aggressive is
different I'm I'm not aggressive you're
acting aggressive you're acting
aggressive I'm not acting aggressive
you're looking aggressive
I'm aggressive Define define define
pedophilia Define pedophilia all I'm
saying no no Define pedophilia Define
pedopilia don't sh at me m I'm talking
to you here where Define pedopilia then
pedopilia Define it who who who who
Who's the majority ped white middleaged
man it's not even our problem it's it's
it's a white middle AG are you are you
British no I'm okay where you from I
don't know where you look like bro where
I'm from yeah well I'm asking you a
question I'm asking okay that's see
that's this what I mean you're not here
you're not here to
listen
question I'm just asking I don't know
okay that's fine no problem no problem
what's your name can I ask you your name
personal information get
what can I call you cuz I need to refer
to okay no problem okay no problem all
right no problem all right so you said
you have an issue with what which is it
the prophet's marriage to
Aisha you have an issue with the
prophet's marriage to Aisha no I just
asked a question why is it um he he
could married a 9-year-old was a
womany woman in your in your in your in
your in your kind of law yes but that's
why I say to you define what's P
because you know what's pedophilia you
know pedophilia do you know what's
pedophilia do you understand let me you
want to be educated I'll educate you
don't just educate me I know what's well
no you need education because you come
in you come in with you come in with a
pretense with a pretense yeah you came
to me to ask me he's taking offense
because I ask question
I'm can can can I can I can I can I just
can I just address it can I can I can
I can I can I can I can I can I address
it thank you okay so you said on the
side it says question exactly and you
have a right to ask question no no I was
just look it's just it's just the
questions I was asking you it's so I can
just get a little background you
questioning me I'm asking you question
no no no my questions was nothing to do
with that it's just look people come
here and I say what's your name my name
is Dave cut my name is no no let's cut
let's go to the to theout to the okay
so what is what is people shouldn't be
dying with 9year olds and and and 10y
old where where in does it tell you
Britain and most in is put in a
dictionary it's not in a dictionary it
says in thean guys let's let's have a
civiliz discussion there's no in the
Quran there's no in the Quran tells you
the age you have to get married doesn't
say that so I read something in the
Quran was saying that he married a
9-year-old there's no way in the Quran
that says
thatth yeah well this another source
yeah okay so let's just break it down
okay so we just understand each other
number one firstly are you a Christian
do you have a just do you have a belief
system cuz I need to know which but but
I need to know because are you an
atheist to ask me
you know why no it's not about yourself
because the thing is your belief system
could contrary to that the reason I'm
asking is because if you're a Christian
it will contradict your beliefs I'm what
I am mate no no it's not I'm asking I'm
saying to you don't worry what I am okay
I'm going to assume you're a Christ okay
I'm going to assume you're a Christian
if you're a Christian if you're a
Christian trying find but no I am M
listen anything to do with me I'm just
going to give you information okay
that's fine that's fine that's fine so
then I I can't really I'll try my best
to address it but but I need know your
world view because if you're not telling
me if you're an atheist you have no but
on what basis on what basis is it wrong
of course it's wrong basye old mate no
no no one second categorically wrong or
consequentially wrong is it
categorically it's wrong no no no one
second on what basis are you coming to
the conclusion that one second, 1400
years one second 1400 ay no no no ask me
would I marry 9y no My Religion doesn't
even tell me to marry 9year oldold so
that's what I'm telling you, 1400 years
ago you what you're doing is you are
applying the the um the laws of not laws
the modern day Norms of today to back
then 1400 years ago now what I'm saying
to is the following the prophet Muhammed
PE him one second he married his first
wife was kij he was 25 years old and his
wife was 15 years older than him he was
married to her for 25 years so I'm
asking you a simple question now before
we put a label on anybody we need to
look at who they are we need to know
information about them yes the prophet
Muhammad if he had these Tendencies he
had nine wives he was married to nine
women only one of them was Aisha who was
six and she became an adult at the age
of nine and that's the norm back then
and even if you look at your great great
grandparents how old were they when you
got married my grandmother was about 13
14 that was the Norms of those Society
so what I'm saying is that you cannot
apply on what basis are you disagreeing
that's I want on what basis I just told
you keep saying on what basis on what
basis what basis what basis what basis
yes what Bas told you I disagree with
the 9-year-old and six-year-old or
whatever
marri okay what's the what's the legal
age Li in this country what's the
illegal age in this country 16 yeah 16
okay no problem what's illegal age in
France country what's my country well
you from Afghanistan thank you see
look no no I'm happy no there's no wrong
Afghan I'm afgh yeah it's wrong it's
wrong I'm I'm from I'm cish from Turkey
oh in my in my 18 it's 18 it's 18 18 but
but again it's we can say it's maybe
secular in France is 15 in America
250,000 girls were married under age
children by the way in America look look
bro in certain cities in in States at 12
years old with per to consent they can
get married is this pedophilia oh yeah
is Americans pedophiles are they
pedophiles Americans I don't know mate
what you mean you don't know know if
Americans are pedophil okay according to
Turkey Turkey age is 18 how do I know
they pedophiles no that's my argument if
you're seeing this the age if the age
makes him a pedophile I'm seeing in my
country Turkey talking about you're just
trying to hear me hear me up in my
country is 18 in the UK is 16 according
to my country this is a pile country why
the 16 why not 18 probably is I don't
know if it is no but this is but that's
the asking a question from but but
that's the argument is flawed if you're
talking about age it's not fled it is
flawed why 16 everyone anyone Ry and ask
him if if it's it's wrong and everyone
yes my friend I'm telling you I'm
telling you Muslim no no no no no no we
said the difference between this the
following in this country the age limit
is what 16 all I'm saying is I disagree
my friend you need to understand what
I'm telling you I'm saying the prophet
Muhammad the prophet Muhammad look him
up the prophet Muhammad peace upon him
look made a marriage contract at the age
of six and waited 3 years why did he
wait 3 years for her to become an adult
the issue you have is exactly because
you're looking at a 9-year-old today and
a 9-year-old back then that's the
problem that's what they're saying
that's what he's saying he's saying he
waited three years he didn't then what
happened why why why did he wait three
years for them okay what was it for what
did it say in
yes years I'm telling you for my
traditions he waited three years you
marry a 9-year-old and then wait
3 years until she's no no no but this is
what I'm saying to you your great
grandparents you will call them a pile
because of the argument you using
because it's called the fallacy of
presentism you're looking at today's age
a 9-year-old there are 23 year olds who
play Playstation Xbox at home agree to
disagree no agree to disagree if you
want to educate if you want to learn
something okay that's fine if we want to
learn something my brother is that no
you're learning something you're
learning something we're both learning
something I'm learning something you're
learning something I learn something
that's a cross so you are a Christian so
according to your belief do you believe
Jesus Is God if you do Jesus in the Old
Testament but why but why are you afraid
of me saying you're a Christian I'm not
afraid me questions again you ask me if
I'm a told you anything to do with me
you're not getting anything you don't
need to cuz I can see a tattoo which
shows you're a Christian there's nothing
WR there's not wrong with it we're
actually close to you guys Allah says in
the Quran we're close to the people of
the book Jesus Is God God of the Old
Testament The Book of Numbers says to
Jesus who's ordered to go to a specific
Nation kill men women children and girls
who are not touched by men to keep them
for yourself and rabbis interpret this
as girls as young as 3 years old do you
cond that I see this on Facebook you
cond that I see this on Facebook where
um ay I approached um Muslim people in
was it high yeah I go there and saying
exactly the same thing I'm asking the
question and we answer it I answered it
and you done exactly what the preacher
done yeah which is show their double
standards inste of to the question think
you kept on going back to 400 years
ago00 years ago started bringing in
Jesus saying oh yeah done this you have
to be consistent as a Christian you have
to be consist jump from your mhamed on
to the Christian yeah yeah well you have
to be consistent look if I if I if I
have look if I do something I think it's
wrong look if I'm a thief and I come to
say why you stealing I'm a thief myself
think it's wronging a 9-year-old and a
what age, 1400 years ago what I'm saying
is no no no no my friend this is what
I'm asking you is it categorically wrong
or consequentially wrong on okay in your
eyes your eyes are
subjective my friend listen to you what
I'm saying me I have a daughter my
daughter is seven nowh in My Religion it
tells me that my daughter has to go get
married at nine because we look at the
harm factor is it she going be harm
there's many factors the age leg in this
country is 16 but a girl who's 16 maybe
is not sexually ready but the legal law
says that you should going have sex do
you know how many Teenage do you know we
have a pandemic of teen teenage
pregnancies in the UK I don't care what
you mean you don't care there are
teenage girls having sex going things
not but but but you have to be
consistent if there's one thing you're
questioning but if you look at your
lands you live in and yourself you're a
Christian and there's things that says
in your book that is worse than that
they have to be consistent that all I'm
saying is I'm disagree
basic why don't you look look why why
don't you read it a good day exactly
there you go